if democrats don't do terribly in  november it will be because of the  temporary trumpist constituency that  only cared about trump and now they've  bailed  and things have gone sort of back to  quote normal that would be one possible  analysis the other possible analysis  would be  that is not the explanation the  explanation would be democrats would  have lost  were it not for  roe v wade being overturned very  unpopular with americans  and nothing being done on gun safety  despite prominent mass shooting after  prominent mass shooting two issues  abortion and guns that are not typically  good issues for democrats in elections  this time around polling suggests might  actually be good issues now all of this  is hypothetical all of this is  if democrats manage to retain control  in one or both houses